[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les prix du lait relâchement pour la
demo pour combiner sur le troisième
motif que le sort
réservé à continuer la lutte pour un
guide évocateur moralement je tiens
parce que je suis un activiste de la
démocratie est aussi un militant des
droits de l'homme donc je savais que
puisque je dénonçais c'était dans
l'intérêt de la population guinéenne
donc je ne regrette rien moi je prends
donc tous en complet que la guinée soit
inopinés nouvelle
[Musique]
nous avons décidé test après avoir
nourri la est actuellement avec nous la
république nous avons décidé de
dissoudre la constitution en vigueur
dissoudre les institutions
l'avons décidé de dissoudre le
gouvernement
[Musique]